I do think that there's a reason why
this whole trans explosion is happening
in these more leftist cities more than
anywhere else and why you have people
like the Disney executive who's like my
one child is polyamorous and my other
child is trans and my other child is a
furry like whatever really because
there's it's no accident that that's
happening because like that that's not
going to happen in my family and I'll
tell you there's another woman who I
knew in New York
um she's black her husband's black and
she said that she was very concerned
about this trans ideology at our school
where they were asking our boys whether
they were concerned whether they were
sure they were boys every week and she
said at home she and her husband were
counter programming like can you imagine
Grandpa showing up in a dress like they
were doing some mild mocking of it so
that their boys understood this is
absurd and not an available option for
you
yeah you know as crazy as it is uh uh
one of the fears Megan you know you've
made a lot of money in your life you're
very successful you're at the top of the
game uh uh you're the best at what you
do okay so that's Megan Kelly you're not
in the top one person you're more like
one percent of one percent okay so
you've been fortunate I've been
fortunate we've done good for ourselves
financially so we can kind of use our
resources to you know push our weight a
little bit right like if you're going
like if I'm interviewing for schools
that I was putting my kids into I went
to seven different private schools here
in South Florida one of my first
question was so hey Mary you know thank
you so much for taking the time for the
appointment uh with us and our three
kids we're looking forward to coming to
Florida how does this school feel about
capitalism excuse me yeah how do you
feel about what do you think about these
rich people these entrepreneurs these
capitalists these business owners who
had what is the school's position on
capitalism
well we we teach the benefits of of
capitalism and the pros and cons of it
but we also teach the pros and cons of
socialism and we teach pros and cons of
Communism and we allow the kids to
decide yeah my kids are not going to go
to your school I mean yeah how much more
history do you need to not have to teach
the pros of Communism how many millions
of people have been killed so these are
the questions that parents with
resources can ask but Megan I want you
to think about this
think if you and I are making seventy
four thousand dollars a year okay
household income we have is 120 let's
say 130 okay 30 of that goes to taxes so
if you're making one Thirty thirty
percent goes to taxes you're left with
ninety seven thousand dollars let's just
say ninety five thousand dollars
you're living in a three-bedroom house
maybe a four bedroom house uh 30 minutes
outside of the city because that's what
we can afford and our kids can only go
to a public school and now you go and
impose yourself with these things so
parents are now coming home and the kids
asking questions about lgbtq then the
parent tries to explain this to the kid
then the kid goes to school and says
well my mommy told me then the Teacher
Calls the parent and says hey you can't
tell that to your kids now the parent is
afraid doesn't know what to do because
they could get kicked out now they're
being boxed in a place that you are a
extremist and all this stuff then the
teachers can Target do you see how this
thing creates the kind of fear and
parents that they're immobilized so that
causes a lot of parents to say well look
babe don't say that to him because he's
going to say that and go hey son you
can't go tell that to your teacher it's
Crea I remember living in Iran with my
parents going to a school and worried
about the Hezbollah pulling us over and
if they ask you are you a Christian you
got to say ask my mommy and my daddy
some parents right now in low and middle
income families are right now going
through this and making I got to tell
you that's a scary place to be you and I
may not know about it today you and I
may not know the fears of that but tens
of millions of people are going through
that today so what do they do what's the
solution is it best to just kind of sit
on the sidelines and let other people
steal your kids for 20 years and I don't
mean physically I mean emotionally and
philosophically and now your kid doesn't
like you because your teachers and the
school system pinned you against your
kids and they come home and they say all
you care about is this what do you do
this is where pitching and complaining
is not enough this is where sitting on
the sidelines and just talking to other
parents and yeah you know Johnny's mom
also feels this way this is when we got
to get involved there's never ever Megan
been a better time or more important of
a time of a side gig do real estate on
the side
do something on the side to create an
additional two three four five thousand
dollars a month to either put your kids
in a private school or to homeschool or
on top of that if you can't do any of
that stuff based on where you live get
involved right now School boards uh the
voting percentage is not that high it
only it's like five percent voting five
to ten percent voting if you go vote or
turnout is not high and parents who run
typically they have a very high chance
of winning so if you're sitting there
saying well I'm not happy about what's
going on run for school board you would
be surprised how many other parents feel
like you and you become the Courageous
one and other people in public school
say I kind of like what Mary has to say
let's get behind her right you have to
find a way of creating that power to
vote with your feet or speak up at
school and be listened to you know it
it's getting easier I mean I will say
it's easier when I was in the city at
the school I just referenced where
they're asking our boys if they're girls
every week
um we form this sort of underground
network of parents and that's where I
met the friend I was telling you and and
as I mentioned that she and her husband
are black they were they didn't did not
appreciate the messages going to their
brilliant son that he was somehow less
than because of the color of his skin
which was the implicit message of
America's original sin and there's
really no way around it and you somehow
are divided from your white and your
Indian your brown skinned classmates and
you Hispanics too you're in the same
boat she and the other parents of color
were as mad as we were
um where they were saying you know as
I've told you the world before about the
white kids in every classroom where
white children learn there's a future
killer cop and teaching that there are a
hundred genders and refusing to refer to
the boys as boys now or as your sons as
Sons now it's just your student this hit
the news just this week that in Vermont
there's this school it's like uh I'll
pull up the name like Founders I can't
remember like friends I've figured out
um where they're they're getting rid of
same thing they're they're only
referring to boys as um
people who make sperm and girls as
people who make eggs
in school now and these parents in
Vermont this is not you know this is
Vermont which is a blue state but come
on it's still America where they're
saying we're getting what is it Essex
Essex
Essex Westford uh in Vermont and this is
being allowed Pat I mean it's being
allowed
yeah this again you know for me
sometimes when I was younger and I had a
bad idea or let's just say a dumb idea
and I would go to my dad and I would say
Dad I want to do this and that would say
okay here we go Pat's got another crazy
idea and I'm 12 years old or I'm eight
years old or I'm 16 years old and he
knows I'm gonna fail and I would go
execute this idea and I don't execute it
because it's a terrible idea and I'll
come back and say you know what that it
didn't work yeah you were kind of right
but of course we don't tell our dads he
was right and we would do more of these
things sometimes it happens in a company
a department comes to you and they say
Patrick we have an idea we need a
hundred thousand dollar budget for this
if it's a hit it could be this it could
be I'm like yeah I'm not going to give
you a hundred thousand dollar budget but
here's 10 grand and go see at the lowest
level and see what you can do and then
come back boom it fails already come
back and it says it works okay
so
the best part about ideas or if somebody
claims watch me you're gonna see what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do something
really special about my life great you
know what's going to validate whether
you do or not time 10 years later people
are going to say no you will really all
talk you were not a doer unfortunately
you've been a talker and that's your
label you get labeled a talker you get
labeled somebody who talks a big game
but doesn't come through in our family
had an uncle that I would always get
compared to because my dad is five nine
five ten I'm six five which is kind of
confusing for Middle Eastern guy to be
six five so everybody will look at the
mailman to see if he was tall no my
dad's brother is six five so I took my
height after this uncle called Johnny
and Johnny had a reputation who was the
smartest guy who would smoke a pipe and
he would read physics books for a hobby
who the hell reads physics books well my
uncle Johnny would do that and he was my
favorite uncle he would take us to this
place uh that he would buy me Nutella in
Iran if you eat Nutella you're
apparently Rich so I would eat Nutella
every six months and you know you would
kind of experiment I really love this
Uncle Johnny one day my dad tells me
uncle Johnny's reputation and what his
nickname is his nickname was 70 Johnny
what's 70 Johnny Johnny was the smartest
guy in our family great with numbers
great but a lot of different things and
he would always go and start a project
and he would go to 70 of completion and
he would stop
Stop So eventually everybody said man
John you got great ideas but you never
execute today all of these people that
are coming up with these trans able you
know as well I I identify as blind I
identify as this Dwyane Wade uh said
well you know I can't uh identify myself
as somebody that can live in a state of
Florida it's two extreme of policies
with what the governor is doing there
you know with a trans kid I have decided
to take my kids to a different place no
problem yeah you know today he may seem
like a noble parent
and it may look like what a sweet father
what a great mother you guys are you
know obviously the biological mother
didn't support it but you know Dwyane
Wade more power to you but in 10 years
when that kid is 25 years old on 20
years when that kid is 35 years old that
kid is going to say why'd you let me do
that as a 13-14 I had no clue what I was
doing why'd you let me make a decision
like that why don't you wait till I was
an adult why did you do that Dad then no
we are all gonna realize whether that
decision that was made in 2023 or 2022
it was a bad decision and unfortunately
Megan this is the problem unfortunately
some of these shitty ideas these guys
are coming up with that are seeming like
they're such noble people it's going to
take 10 to 20 years to realize they were
horrible ideas and a lot of people
especially helpless people like kids are
going to suffer the consequences so as
loud as many of us are going to be as
much as we're going to go out there and
present Common Sense unfortunately some
of these bad ideas are creating momentum
and it's hurting the people that are
helpless
[Music]